Ward himself like hired incompetent
staff then faith has no money to pay for
them because he's overpaying these
people that don't know what the
they're doing but they come from
prestigious places but it's just not
what this is because it doesn't work
like they don't know what they're doing
in this industry and then he fronts the
money to pay for them then he gives
himself millions of shares like
everything is chalk bro everyone just be
doing weird again it's all
political you guys don't get paid for
your
no
like even with a Batman Club my face is
on the cover of Batman comic they it's a
huge thing zero dollars almost got zero
dollars from it like nothing they just
play us that's why I'm done bro like I
did it for so long because of our
emotional attachments because we love
phase right like we love this so bro
it's like people won't get it but I
won't do is leave like it's not like
signing the Atlantic like you
don't give a it's different it's
like we built this this is our baby and
we're doing whatever we could for so
long that maybe save it but like it's
just been too late for too long until
unless everybody like boycotted it
essentially but nobody wants everyone's
so whatever that's unfucking
that's the craziest I have ever
heard
[Applause]